well kirsty alley has been an actress
for a long time a famous and successful
one a lot of people acting very few make
it kirstie alley did
so she doesn't need to come out and
destroy her reputation in hollywood but
she did anyway
she came out of the closet as a donald
trump supporter and then
an opponent of the ludicrous hysteria
around the coronavirus
so those two positions landed her in a
lot of trouble
with our friends over on the cable news
network over the weekend
here's part two of our conversation with
christie alley about what happened to
her
chris daley joins us now christine
thanks so much for coming back on the
show
so you have effectively endorsed donald
trump
you don't need to you don't get anything
out of it why did you do that
you know i'm not usually very outspoken
about politics but
i did it because i i feel like he's
actually
a person who is
kind of like me you know i'm from the
midwest and yeah
if i was gonna run for president i would
just really want to do it to help the
country i wouldn't have any other
ulterior motive because i'm not a
politician so
i like the idea that some guy comes in
and you know he's sort of rough and
tough that's okay with me and like i
said i'm from the midwest we're all
rough and tough
and he i really believe earnestly has
the best interest of this country and he
just
you know he just wants to make
everything better and he has some good
statistics
so i like how what he did with the
economy i like what he did with the jobs
i like you know a lot of people go like
with the way he talks do i like the way
he talks
not all the time but i'd rather you know
he's like a rough and tough guy and the
other guys are like snakes
so would i rather be up against rough
and tough yelling out or would i rather
have snakes around me being all covert
and lying and
so i i just got really tired of it well
you must have it because i voted for
obama twice and then i'm like okay you
guys had your fair shot
you really didn't do much of anything
and i really had thought
that they were going to do something
really amazing for the black
community and i don't think they did and
so i thought you have your eight years
i'm going the other direction now and
i just can't get you know on twitter i
get all these remarks
and they're all so stupid and i i don't
mean that all democrats are stupid but
the ones that are trying
to
[Laughter]
but i mean you could have just been
silent about it what happened when you
went public i mean
it just seems like if you live in your
world there's a huge downside to doing
that
well you know oh come on talk look i
mean i in
2016 i was doing a show
and i won't i don't need to talk about
the show i was doing but i was on a set
and i knew that it was
i had people come up to me and they were
like whoa if
you know we're with you but if we say
this we're going to never work again
and i thought you know look i'm over 60
how many parts are there for actresses
anyway
so what do i have to lose you know
so i thought i'm just going to say the
way i feel and i'm rep i feel like i'm
representing you know i'm representing
my family my friends my and it's not
that i don't have friends who are
democrats but they have plenty of people
representing them in hollywood they
don't
they don't need me to represent them so
i'm going to represent
my way of life and and my values and my
people well i'm just i'm just
fascinated by people who go against the
grain
and in your world what you just did was
a pretty brave thing and i'm just
impressed and i would say that even if i
didn't agree with you i mean that i
think it's a cool thing that you did i'm
glad that you
told our viewers about it christie ali
great to see you thank you for that
thank you for having me